afternoon Dev
session and that is perfect timing as
well
because we have pretty much this whole
set of experiments
done oh that's interesting we've got
this
like these two peaks at 10 mil and 5 mil
now nothing in between you see
weird Okay so let's let's actually
compare this now
to let's compare this to the previous
one believe this one
here okay so this is this is the one
from before on the right side
I can find the Pito
front believe we got a solve in well
this is CIS running time wait
what in the hell
sub2 second
solt we have a
sub several actually sub 202
solts this one
is about 30C
solve okay that is crazy
do it didn't do anything out here but I
mean I don't do I blame it it's freaking
solved it in 20 seconds like
consistently I don't see anything in the
21 range I don't think
20.6 yeah 20.6 okay and then there it
still goes down to 5
mil that is
nuts 202nd
PA I'm really curious to see what's
different here
okay learning
rate this one finds o4
about this one doesn't do as well over
there though I mean it looks like it
just didn't fill in a gap but there's
definitely I mean a different Peak here
that's very
weird I mean this one it seems like it's
getting
better huh then
gamma okay gamma's just pushed all the
way to 0 n99
here gamma is a stable region
here uh okay
Lambda
0.95 there are a lot of experiments
around
here again sort of like a wider
spread update
EPO mostly one or
two okay so this one has landed on two
epochs
consistently we had some some of both of
these mostly one but some
to Value function
coefficient
0.6 there are like actually several
slightly different points
here 0.6 and here actually we do have
the best points around
0.6
0.9 and here it's yeah this is very
different
00005 I mean this one's pretty stable so
you can't really look at that much
uh this one probably doesn't matter very
much it's just more samples here so at
whatever and then we'll do poo clost
last I want to look at numm in the other
scaling PRS CU those are going to be
different okay so
here they actually both find the best
around 512 amp
right back
batch this does use bigger mini
batch that could be the speed difference
for most of its runs at
this does put runs down to 20 but
they're not
good
huh we still have this sort of problem
over
here man that's so weird
holy we get a good result but the
opposite of the result I
expected welcome YouTube
folks for those who just popped in um I
ran an experiment we have Pawn solved in
seconds but the reasoning behind this is
very
weird I'm defining 20 above 20 scores
solved here it's a Max of 21 um you know
perfect play would be you consistently
get 20 21 but you know generally if
you're getting 20 points it's
solved I mean we have all these points
between
20 what just happened here as well
didn't this just did this refresh weird
sis running
cost and this kind of curve is very
weird as well makes me think you could
solve this in like 12 seconds or 13
seconds
okay so there are two sort of graphs I
want to look at here so first where's
the score over
time sweet progress okay this is your
sweet
progress here's this sweet press
says far fewer points that are at 20 to
be
fair this one has way more points that
are at
20 then if we look at these two
curves this is just finished so we can
have these last few
I'm almost wondering if it's worth
downloading this data in order to see
yeah I think it is I think what we're
going to do is we're going to download
this and we're going to look at the
sampling distribution
here maybe we can do something
reasonable with this
welcome I do we have
[Music]
a what this is w b I thought there was a
script for Neptune that I
there we
go the tag here is
get the
[Music]
token and we're going to do some
analysis
on these
results and we'll see how we can improve
so also gives a sensitivity for a bunch
of stuff doesn't
curve interesting that a lot of the
latest runs are the bad ones out
here that's really
weird and then if we I guess if we look
at the parito points on
this
actually has to be a different one
this actually has to be a different one tedo
source
okay so this is what the parito front
looks
these just copy this oops I'm just going
to do
this okay
so this curve is just this stretched
we can also see now with the red which
points are more recent on the
right so according to this this is not
running
bad lowcost experiments at the end
right the thing that I don't understand
right is
why so you get this Paro Point
here okay and then you stop trying to
expand outward
it's interesting to me that it is
actually trying some of these new
points and they're not
working maybe we need to look at some of
those h on did I switch these windows up
where's the other window because this is
the the wrong
one this goes
here so some of these points at the
bottom are actually very new
apparently like this one or this one
here and there are all new literally
what this coloration is wrong hang
on something weird
D oh is it in a reverse
order yeah it's in a reverse
order
okay so that's going to actually be a
very different
story for
okay so this tells a completely
different story then right
and this is more in line with what we
expected from
earlier so this is all good but then it
does this Shenanigans at the end one two
three four five six yeah lots of these
clustered bad experiments
here all very close to minimum score as
well
zero so presumably they're just a bunch
of parito points there and it's randomly
sampling or
Behavior how far up do we have to go
before we get a nonzero
rating and I mean obviously like these
could have decimals on them
okay I mean this is good
right go down a little
bit yeah look at this we're doing well
we're doing reasonable
predictions and then at some point
so you're still good at
zero my guess here is that at some
point yeah you can actually can you see
it down here right at some point about
halfway through the
sweep boom we get this
collapse or at least it's not a total
collapse either you still have a lot of
points up here but at least it seems
like it stops making forward
progress can we see it on the cost
graph where's our cost
graph earning
rate yeah cost okay yeah we can I think
we can see it kind
of yeah right here it goes from this 20
and it sort of splits into
and these freaking scores are like it
doesn't you can't click them it doesn't
obnoxious there we
go yo I made my PRD Dev for Tower climb
awesome we will merge
that so you can start uh playing with it
and we'll make sure it's a clean
merge test pass then we will merge this
for now and hopefully they uh we'll hope
that it just works
take a quick
upgraded to
cool and you put our path stuff back in
that seems to work I
guess wait did you is it statically
linked still or did you change
that oh man do you have it back to
dynamically linked
it okay so here's the issue right the
issue is that python is really stupid
and if you dynamically link stuff
inevitably on some system it will [ __ ]
up and it won't have this on the path so
what happens is as soon as you go to you
try to import puffer lib from outside of
the puffer lib directory uh you get an
error a linking error because somehow
python has [ __ ] up The Path so that's
why we did this to avoid
that I don't even know if that's
Bulletproof
I guess I can merge this I will just
have to I mean you've done enough stuff
on this so I will just merge it um
potentially I will have to do some work
though and
oops and we will get some builds going
on this
awesome there I'm in the middle of this
oblations work but we will do some uh
some testing on your new M quite
soon so that's a pretty awesome new end
so thank you for
that that was quite a
signal uh sometimes sometimes not look
generally just like python is python is
really [ __ ] at linking stuff so it will
eventually mess it will eventually mess
up your path and cause po lip to not
work outside the puffer lib
directory um I merged
it but uh they will probably do some
stuff and we do not want it dynamically
linked you replace the a for static link
you replaced it with a
doso um that's going to cause problem so
I'll have to mess with it but you've
done a bunch of work so I've just merged
it for
yeah that would be ideal if you if you
PR that that that would be ideal for
sure
long and later
awesome that'll be
good hello trying to create a puffer hen
open the work in P progress PR yep let
me look
you're going to end up pring this
probably to Dev or something instead of
to
main let me
yeah I'm looking at
it you can also always just link me your
fork um
nice we're always happy to have uh like
industry adjacent M this is cool
I don't know I didn't even I didn't know
about this at all usually people chat in
the Discord or whatever about stuff
they're planning on building but this is
a nice
surprise um let's see
environment very good I'll check this
one next and then I'll go up back
work you definitely want to have that
work as a priority um if you let me know
what's wrong with that you should yeah
that would be good because the thing is
uh building it for python every time is
just miserable like all of your good
debug information comes from the seu
belt like it is dramatically
dramatically easier to uh write the
envin C build with just you know build
in pure C get the actual correct
compiler messages and the way faster
build times and then you uh do the PX
and you'll make it work that
way so I do strongly strongly recommend
otherwise it's hard right like puffer
lib is supposed to be easy but if you
try to go through the python compilation
for everything it's not going to be
easy what are you debugging with do you
compile with the local mode from the
build
script that should give you f sanitized
which will catch pretty much everything
and give you nice warnings since uh nice
warnings and error
messages print up in line I would
suggest using GDB at the very least um
um yeah I would I would suggest at least
just use
GDB and I haven't done any cev on stream
in a little while here unfortunately I
miss it
um but yeah I generally my what I do is
I run the build ocean sh script or
whatever compile the local file and then
uh I fix any errors that I know how are
fixed and anything I don't know why is
broken I use GDB
okay so this is a massive observation
space here uh if you give if you put
data that is
this this range into a neural network
this needs to be normalized or will
crash learning no C experience for
looking on trips so the cool thing about
the way that we use C right is that uh
we don't do anything that a firste CS
undergrad having taken in their first
systems course wouldn't be able to
understand we're writing if statements
for and while loops and that's about it
like we're using it in a way that is
very very simple uh and it makes it very
easy to write fast simulation code
without getting hung up on
anything all of the environments that we
have sered as
examples like you can look at everything
from squared for a really basic template
all the way up to like neural MMO 3 for
something more complex
Max searches plus Max TR okay it's just
single discrete Space
full we have a a logging thing for this
if you look at any of the environments
there's this like mean and log function
uh we just have some logging code you
can grab it from pong or from any of the
other ends it's just in the top of theh
you can just paste that in and then you
have a little logging library that plays
nicely and see how we integrate that and
that'll let you get all sorts of stats
from your environment into the python
very easily and
efficiently test perf yeah perf test
cool s
hey did you need to do stuff here to
make this
work you just
moved interesting if there're compile
bugs we definitely need to know about
those we don't want compile
oh okay yeah so uh I think if you're on
Mac you're probably going to want to use
a recent version of clang because you
really really really want the F
sanitized Flags to work for development
and uh older compilers like a lot of the
even like pretty recent but not like
really recent compilers on Mac they
don't give you f sanitized so like C is
hard because of buffer overflows and
memory leaks and stuff but the thing is
these don't actually exist if you
compile with appropriate settings uh you
really want to have access to those
settings ton of
constants Target got
okay if you say you have no C experience
I mean you're doing some things
here and unless you were using GPT
heavily or
something like I see just from the types
you're
using snake undergrad
experience is all you need that's
literally all I know as
well like the the thing is I think that
you think that there's stuff that you
need to learn here in order to do this
there's nothing else that you need to
learn here like it's very very basic
C by Design we don't like fancy
things for context I wrote python for
the last 10 years and then I've been
writing C in the last six months and I
already it's already easier for me
writing like new environments very
complex stuff even in C than it is in
Python using just the other
Basics but you're shooting yourself in
the foot not having good compile
settings you're making it way harder
than it should
What specifically do you want feedback
or help for on this uh on this
environment code I can just open the
full file
just First
Reactions yeah I mean that's it it's
it's pretty much just like write your C
code like don't compile the python every
time in order to try to Dev your C use a
new compiler make sure you're using the
F sanitized flags that we have in there
so that you actually get good error
messages and just like enjoy writing
like really fast code without having to
do anything particularly complicated in
order to do
it that's sort of the magic of
this is you can just write really simple
C and uh puffer lib uh hooks into the
observations of that so it's able to
keep your performance throughout the
whole
stack and looking here I just see a
bunch of math basically
right I haven't I haven't seen anything
like particularly made and
silly I mean it was would be pretty easy
for me to like get this thing to not be
indented five layers but that's just
style
stuff whatever this silly formatting but
like I'm not seeing anything that's like
particularly
like this just a bunch of Math logic
geometry yeah I mean other than the
nesting and the crazy I don't know if
this is your editor formatting or
something but other than that in the
crazy spacing like I don't see I don't
see anything like intrinsically
ridiculous like you're not doing any
dynamic memory allocations that I've
seen which is
good it's just like a bunch of Math
logic like yeah you can probably clean a
a bunch of stuff up by like caching
variables a little bit smarter and
stuff but that's just that's just
programming in general right that's
nothing to do with
something yeah and you're definitely
going to want something like this
working well yeah you can have very long
Horizon environment that's
fine how long between rewards is the
main
question like how long do you go between
rewards that's the thing that matters
more like how sparse is
it when like yeah we have continuing
envir like we have continuous envir like
continual environments as well like the
big one that I wrote is this one right
this is neural MMO 3 if it loads I mean
this thing is pretty darn
massive right we have way larger Maps
than this as well this is just what I
could fit on the web like all these like
NPCs and objects drain and levels
economy all sorts of stuff and this
thing will just keep
running hey you kept the puffer color
for this I like that
rewards related
to underlying filter State just trying
to reduce
variance got trouble learning any
everything as everything is muddied out
to the point actions don't
matter well the thing that helps with
that right is one having relatively
clean environment code and two having it
be human playable so that you can like
fiddle with your environment see if you
get rewards when you expect to get
rewards right you can like look at your
observations and make sure that the
observations are what they should
be the vast vast majority of problems in
reinforcement learning are your rewards
aren't what you think they are and your
observations are computed wrong
honorable mention to you're not
resetting the environment the way that
you
think those are the vast majority of
problems in RL
but like the funny thing about that
right is that that's just straight up
like that's just straight up
engineering right so you're not really
missing any background in order to do
this
stuff so I mean the best advice I can
give you here is that other than like
compiling it in a way that makes your
life easier you're not really missing
anything
fundamental yeah you're not really
missing anything fundamental
um you just need to make your Dev life a
little easier clean up some code a
little bit make it human playable so
that you can like see what's going on
with it and then that and then once you
have that then if you need some
assistance with like getting it to learn
our stuff
absolutely but that's what I would
suggest doing
first and then this looks like it could
be a pretty cool environment we are
always happy to PR new stuff and hey if
you keep stuff open source like this and
you're willing to PR it then you get
assistance as well in integration so I
can help you even get some policies
running on this and
whatnot very
good go back to the ablation stuff if
that's all on
yeah Spencer if you're here I got puffer
box zero back up and running as
well I need to figure out a couple
things with this sweep thing before we
really start running uh experiments
but we now have a box
back and I've gotten the process pretty
quick so if I need to fix any of the
other
ones I can uh reinstall the OS to a bun
to pretty quickly
we should absolutely put the memory
limits on the containers going forward
though I think you and that guy are just
out of memory yourself into
could I just
train a GP on this real
just doesn't know how to improve after
this I
guess justes know what to improve
I just tweeted something that might
be I might have tweeted the answer to my
own problem
it's probably making the Gan process
never
predict it like can't beat this point
it's the
thing and then when we did log cost why
did that was something
different cuz we had something else here
so this is one Paro front
had this
one no not this
this is a
20.4 but the thing is like this is
20.4 I think we got a 20.8 or something
here
right
yeah so it's trying to still beat this
thing
20.4
2.7.7 and it kind of stops trying even
though it should be easier out here
there's just a lot of
noise it's annoying as well
because
okay continue to play with it
we could run this on breakout to see
what it
way we preserve the local box for
whatever I
well we'll leave this alone I'll put
this on the
side and uh we will
see how that
useful so let's see if we can figure
something out
here I removed the log the log from the
cost
I want to see how this gets filled in
over time which is why I'm doing this
manually so these are the random samples
right boom 20
it's interesting that the uh there's
such a difference with that log term
versus no log term huh
something so it's going to
be log
xus
log uh
is I just want to make sure it's the
same shape
shifted there we
go oh no it's it's definitely a little
bit
uh yeah it's definitely a bit different
here
interesting how's Florida Florida is
good starting to get a little bit hot
but it's good so
far I have some work to do before I get
back to
California have to do some work on a
site for the new hardware and stuff
we're
doing that's good there's like literally
nothing to do other than hang around and
exercise and work which is exactly how I
like it
this is one two so this is not log
scaled
right so so this is 100
[Music]
million this is very weird because this
like this experiment has given me the
opposite result of what I expected while
giving me like higher quality results
order of magn like higher quality
results overall but the uh qualitatively
it's the opposite of what I
lion that is so
confusing what did I
weird I mean it could just be completely
that these things
are I could run it again it could be
that these things are just noisy
because we got a really good sample
early
like maybe I just can't complain about
the result because the result is we you
know the m is solve what more do you
want the solved you got a good per curve
what more do you want
right and some of them are going to be a
bit
noisy but you have like a fair few like
this
a little bit of instability around here
but
solved in 20 seconds to solved in 20
seconds
okay and what about
our breakout
one this is not a good Fredo front for
breakout after all right
cost is there something screwy with the
log that I'm not like I'm not
oh I mean I guess yeah the log okay the
other experiment aside the log on the
cost would explain this it'll try to
group everything near the low cost
region if it can't figure out the score
at the very
this you can just see the amount of
noise and the inconsistency in a lot of
these curves
well and literally while I'm looking at
it it just totally crashed the score
again well this will have to be
experimental we'll have to just run a
bunch of experiments to get this
yeah maybe we can spend a little time
thinking about the core algorithm though
right
now if I have any other
ideas cuz there's some things I'm still
not happy with but let's do that that'll
be interesting I'll like do a bunch of
diagrams and I'll Think through some of
the MTH
and uh maybe we'll come up with some
more stuff as well use a restroom I'll
be right back and then we'll go do that
grab a drink as
here you know there's something I
haven't tried in quite a
while and I don't think it would work
based on what I've seen here but I'm
going to do it anyways just to try
because you know what's the harm
here hey Joseph today I started learning
prologue at University have you seen use
prologue the
heck that and uh yeah this
is
what they teach
idea that's
bizarre yeah know that's bizarre that's
a new
one I mean hey in the US they teach Java
so can it possibly be worse than
that I mean I guess technically you can
use Java at a job that you'll hate but
that'll pay you well so I guess there's
that the algorithm classes were in Java
no that's
insane you literally can't do the
algorithm class without having
pointers L new language I find it
bizarre well that would that should not
be particularly difficult once you're
more experienced to be
honest fourth year bachelor's I don't
know I did my CS degree core my first
year and then I just did research and
stuff after that
the thing that's driving me crazy late
lately
holy what the heck M
so let me explain the thing that's been
bothering me right
so the way the algorithm works at the
moment
whoops is that if you have a point here
and a point here and this
is terrible Line This is
cost then in order to evaluate how good
a new point is here here what you do is
you look at this distance
here and you look
at
Min of these two
distances possibly in log
space and you call this a and you call
this B and you do a
*
B and that's your scoring function so
what this is telling you to do is
improve over the nearest Paro optimal
point to your left so do better than the
current best thing and also try to fill
in the curve right try to put points
that are far away from existing
points so it does tell you it tells you
to explicitly fill in this cost
curve but this is not quite what we want
you to
do we want you to fill
in your goal should be to fill in this
cost curve
subject to spending the minimum total
amount of
compute which is not quite what this
thing
specifies but every single effort that
I've had in order to uh to attempt to
get something to work on that has done
this where it doesn't explore at all
because it's like well I'm not going to
pay the extra cost to run these
I'm trying to think if there's any way
around that
see the key thing that's difficult here
right is that this value B however
you're going to express it this is the
amount of
improvement all right and then you're
going to divide the amount of
Improvement by the
cost but you really don't have any idea
of the scale of this
thing or how much you
you see I mean this isn't going to
really do
much actually it did kind of do
something interesting
here it uh yeah it did this backwards
line
fell okay hold on maybe there is
something
here cuz look it did actually it did
this jump and then it did this like line
fill
backwards and then it did this line fill
okay so maybe it is smart maybe it's
just outwitting me I've seen this
problem
before this is because you're telling it
to improve over the nearest burito
Point um but you are
not the way to improve over the nearest
burito point right is that you go
you go like you pick a point that's far
out and then you improve over the near
freedo point you just go a little to the
left and do it again and you repeat
okay maybe there's something we can work
with
okay I have I have an idea let me figure
out how to implement this
we describ
as absolute cost
difference we're just going to try some
variations on uh the ideas that I have
you know while I'm waiting for
experiments to run maybe I hit on
something good you never know
so what's going on with this C curve
here in the
meanwhile this is literally just
improvement over nearest Paro Point
divided by cost
matches the full 200 well no 110 was the
number
110 I'm going to give it 200 runs on the
suspicion that it probably is more uh
that it probably does more shorter runs
anyways trying to think about this in
the meantime
though this would be such like an
enticingly
simple algorithm if we could get it to
work
it's actually not that far off if you
think about it from what I previously
did so I was previously I was
Computing both distance to nearest Paro
Point improvement over nearest Paro
point to the left and distance to
nearest point
right I think that's what I was
so I've just merged these two to
essentially just
be uh improvement over
right so then the smart thing to
do right for improvement over nearest
point is you pick two Paro points or
near improvement over nearest Paro point
so you just pick the point like slightly
to the left of middle between these two
right you're able to still get rewarded
if you improve prove over an existing
Paro point
identically I think it's actually
possible this is quite
good now I also added in the divide by
cost
term so next experiment will be without
one I don't think it's hackable I don't
think it is hackable we'll
see I'm actually very interested in
whatever this
is I recently had to have two root no uh
two cavities one freaking root canal one
drilled very deep still causes
I mean this is
covering a lot of the space just not as
quickly as you would want it to
see this is also possibly a best case
scenario because this is a log curve a
lot of the things are not going to be on
a log
curve we'll try without the divide by
cost as
well it should work without the divide
by cost term come to think of
going it die or is it just
slow no it's just
slow does that mean it's doing long
runs well I guess these are just the
random
ones all right so that's some good
random data now we'll start doing
carbs or protein whatever we're going to
call
spacing very dense right
here I bet if we do it with
um let's see if we do it without the
divide by
cost I'm curious because I think that
this would be very similar to the
previous algorithm
just
simpler so this could be a legitimate
Improvement and then we'd have to think
about why it doesn't work with the
divide by
cost and how we can uh fix
line for Simplicity we'll assume we have
a point at Max cost and a point at M
I think that this actually has the
property we want in the sense
that this should approximate for a
straight line This is approximating a
binary search on the transformed
score and this algorithm would be very
similar to the previous one as well
too what about this divide by cost
thing maybe I'm maybe I was wrong about
this so the origin of the divide by cost
term in my head is like you're going to
pay you're going to pay cost to run this
experiment right so you want to maximize
information gain per
cost we have this one here with the cost
term this one without it
mean went for a hard run this
morning did hard de DPS
yesterday I mean I get plenty of
exercise believe me
I don't think they've been sinking to
straa lately for some reason I should
check
that but
um yeah I'm trying to get back my old uh
my old strength in cardio from before I
was
sick there's good
progress still waiting on some of the
strength equipment and have it all set
up at home
and I have to go to the gym and get sick
there we should use the percentile curve
more often
bad I'm really interested to see what
this does on the percentile type task
that'll be more
the other thing I was thinking about
which would
be we can't test with this but would go
absolutely
crazy uh would be if we use during
training we use the entire cost curve to
learn from so instead of treating each
experiment as a data point we take the
cost curves we smooth them and then we
use the whole cost curve is training
data I mean that's how you could
potentially get
um you could potentially cut down the
number of samples several fold that
way cuz then you're getting information
over like the whole cost area and you
just have to figure out the individual
hypers I think we're going to end up
doing that
it kind of just depends like on one hand
I'd like to just get this research out
and done with but on the other hand this
is literally in my mind the most
valuable thing I can be doing for
reinforcement
learning it's like a niche area that
almost nobody bothers to do that has
huge huge potential impact across the
whole field
curve how high up do we get we get
nine 9
[Music]
N this is a pretty good
curve probably avoid some
issues this is worth running
point it's a really Snappy simple
algorithm
I think we just run this on pong and see
what the what it does
if this does comparably I mean this
would be a very nice
simplification should be about the same
as well
data how to get access to the whole
train curves for training the
GP it's a reasonable thing to do right
think
so that should let you SE it with just
one run as well and be even
think that could be heavily worth it
though all right well let's play with it
a little bit
see that's a little bit annoying because
then you don't know which
hypers oh no you can still get it from
ARS and know you can still get it from
ARS this
and there's no reason we can't at least
run tests while uh pong is running here
so we'll go ahead and do
that this will make it easier to uh this
will make it easier to use the
Sweep with a whole cost curve
use
me that should not have worked
go we'll make sure that this still works
and then we can integrate the
uh the rest of
sweeps we now have 17 trials
here that kind of do something
cool we have so far similarish looking
stuff
here Pito front
31 seconds for 18
currently see if this
improves then we will
compare just rest from real quick and
then uh what we're going to do is we're
going to figure out how to get the whole
train curs to be utilized for sweeps I
don't know if that's going to do a ton
for Paul we'll see but uh be right back
okay this is not seriously going to be
different
right it looks like this could be
okay you just have to confirm that I
didn't break anything with doing
that oh yeah this the percentile task
okay for the percentile task that's CL
are fine yeah 999 yeah yeah this this is
totally good so we'll just uh we'll
visualize that graph as soon as it's
done it's going to be a little
tricky interesting or tricky I think to
uh to get the
okay yeah great so this is this is
totally a okay
right interesting that we have a couple
points at the end
here that's totally
fine fact this is pretty damn near
perfect
and this is actually the type of curve
we should probably optimize more for
because a lot of them look like
the what you get back from the
environment your estimates have to be
smooth
we usually we adjust logging we adjust
the report interval not based on
smoothness WE adjust it based on having
the local
dashboard all
we're kind of just tacking on this thing
at the moment I'm obviously going to
clean all this up nicely for the users
okay that's some good data
right that's some very nice
data very chill stream today
thanks yeah well we're kind of just
fiddling with algorithms
this is going to be really really cool
when it works though
interpolate oops wrong type of
window just do it
yeah we're just going to throw a linear
andp on
um on the score data I'd say
making a little bit of a mess here
but I think it's worth doing this just
to get something to
something like
this how's our Palm sweep going while
I've been working on this
should be something by now
right and this is
seconds yeah it'll definitely find some
good stuff
here was looking very similar to
before we'd have to confirm to exactly
the same or not
but looks very similar to before quite
reasonable so I'm not going to worry if
we accidentally kill this in the process
of running
um some new
experiments I think this will be pretty
darn
these resamples are really doing
anything
yeah I think we rerun for
this this will be a very nice comparison
I'll kill this if this doesn't
um doesn't do anything
I don't know if this has been done
before
honestly I think any sort of learning
rate schedule probably breaks this
unless you handle that
um pretty darn good overall I mean maybe
not even come to think of it
now it depends how you do the schedule
how you would do a how you would do the
schedule I
so this is now getting 10 times as much
data for training uh for training the
Gin processes to decide this
weep we'll see whether that's useful or
not
I'll be right back in use a restro we'll
see how this week goes we'll fix it if
though I don't know if this is going to
be massively better we will
see the place where I think that this
could be really important is for much
longer
experiments where uh you really need to
get a lot of data out of each
experiment so know having a a sub sample
ever you 10 million steps or every
certain number of steps could really
help it's interesting that it's getting
so many bad points though
well I did kind of ask it to bootstrap
off of one point instead of doing the
random
trials so if IID run the original it
would have been one two
three these would have all just been
random
so we'll see how quickly it learns from
go so I mean it's not completely failed
it just took it a little bit didn't like
destabilize or
something I mean the trade-off is you
don't have to do random samples
technically you
could you could still do that
but this could be
better it is very obnoxious to have to
do 10 random search
Trials uh every single time you do an
experiment as
well I think this will be
better what'll be interesting to see is
how this does you know a little bit
later
on if this can like uncover the full
curve in 50 instead of 200 or something
like that 50 instead of 100 even would
be
awesome from getting the full cost curve
information so two very important
modifications to the algorithm today the
first mostly keeps it the same but
simplifies the math quite a bit and the
explanation of it it's just improvement
over the nearest pero point
that's the whole algorithm it's just
know maximum improvement over nearest
pero point
you can see how difficult these curves
are to
predict so I mean given that it's a I
figure that given it's going to be a
very noisy estimate
anyways you'd rather have a lot of noisy
data than a little bit of noisy data
since there's really no way to make it
not be a noisy estimate because there's
seed to seed variant in RL
right like you run the same experiment
multiple times you don't get the same
result all the time so given that
instead of just trying to make that like
that one data point really really
accurate and then depend a lot on it
it's better to have a whole bunch of
noisy data points they're going to be
noisy anyways
does it's kind of all the stuff I wanted
to
do time is it oh it's 540 already
doesn't make sense to start something
else let's take a quick look at the
Discord and see if I've missed anything
in
here in the
meanwhile I just was seeing
let's
see this
thing the same
Improvement
huh you know this a this xaxis is very
painful
here why is this not a
billion Oh I thought this was from uh my
bad dude I thought that this this was
from a
paper I thought this was from an
existing paper if you hadn't said that
nobody would have
known but uh
okay from the syllabus paper very nice
that's
cool and domain randomization is the
Baseline
I got static working good job Spencer
you can go ahead and PR
that can show it I don't care it's
fine um which
is which is SFL versus LP cuz we're
currently doing the Minecraft like
curriculum learning progress thing for
uh for
puffer and uh it would be good to know
if that's reasonable
we kind of want the best thing that
doesn't involve an llm to start
one sec we find yeah it would be good to
know because we are doing curriculum
stuff on um on puffer Ms at the
moment we're also attempting to do
massively so to hyper parameter
tuning uh that's where the method is
from
see okay this is a different one I think
was this the one that was just prevented
presented at
nurs yeah learning progress one
I think I was
suspicious no I I forget if it was this
one I was suspicious
been I think I saw these two M's and I
was like yeah okay you know this is not
a real
task that's LP in the plot okay so this
is SFL
oh wait a second I think I remember this
one collect
learnable Oh I thought I thought that
this one was really freaking stupid
this one's massively more compute
expensive isn't
it well no I think it's it's massively
computer expensive
they're not training on these
levels you train on all the levels with
the curriculum
while you should train on all the levels
that you're using like like you should
train on all of these
yeah you shouldn't do that you should
just train on everything I would
[Music]
assume top K
levels learnability and then do they
give this learnability
thing how's this even different then
yeah that would be useful because we're
doing some stuff with Aaron on
um on some puffer
Ms yeah no of course we can chat
whenever I've also been working on my
own algorithms lately and uh
hyper pram tuning that'll be pretty
cool this is their
SFL all right cool I mean I can go do
that real quick before dinner let me
just end stream
here randomly a lot of people tune in
whenever I end up chatting this but um
so yeah for folks
on on Twitch and
YouTube I don't care if we talk on
stream cool then we can you can just do
that that's even easier I'll hop in the
progress it's more fun when these are on
stream
anyways hey what's up man hey how's it
going oh I have to mute stream there we
go
yeah we're going to chat about this and
I'm going to dinner and then uh do you
know what today
is uh uh no you play games don't
you yeah it's the new OverWatch
season
oh I forgot about are are they releasing
the patch today I think so yeah God save
you yeah I know I've been playing Marvel
Rivals oh jeez that's even worse all
right
I think they're both equally awful this
is fair I miss when I played a
respectable game like
valerent I don't have windows installed
because that's more
addictive yeah that's that's a good call
I also I think we're very close to
having hyper Prem tuning for RL
salt I'm excited for that I've actually
spent the past I think two three weeks
just doing hyperparameter tuning for the
syllabus paper not because I give a [ __ ]
because I I don't need to tune most of
these methods they it does almost
nothing but reviewers will complain if I
don't hyper PR to you
everything when you actually throw our
hyperr alks on are you just using random
well okay the problem is that the
methods don't work on two of the
environments that I'm tuning them on but
it's like you can't just say they don't
work if you don't tune them so I'm
tuning them and they look exactly the
same it's just pissing me
off yeah well we've got uh the current
one sentence version of the algorithm is
uh optimal improvement over nearest
parito
point I mean that sounds like a lot of
good things yeah and I also I just
modified it I don't think any algorithm
has done this before that I've seen uh
we're now using the whole learning curve
as data for training the the models used
by the hyper parameter tuning out them
instead of just like the final point oh
that's awesome yeah so we'll see how
that does that'll take some tuning to
get right you gotta tune sounds cool
yeah it's been a lot of work but it's
been good anyway so yeah we are doing
some curriculum learning stuff actually
like formally with puffer now um sweet
we have the mazm obviously that I made
so it's just a million step per second
or more maze environment M that's like
procedurally generable different levels
it's good for exploration it's good for
curricular learning right yeah uh so we
have that and the first method that I
thought to to try was the Minecraft one
cuz it seemed like the simplest one that
was reasonable and that had like a
really cool result come out of it well
that is implemented and baselined in
syllabus now perfectly matches the
original implementation so if you want
to do that it works let me just message
that to
Aaron um Aaron Darna yeah oh he's
working on that with you nice oh yeah
well I'm down to get in on this then
that sounds like a fun team up
uh yeah so uh the thing that happened
here by the way which is why I didn't
think of you initially for this thing
was that uh the initial research
discussion of topics were in a somewhat
different
area sure yeah so that's why that
happened otherwise because I do I have
you on my list of people
for well yeah I mean if you want to do
that curriculum it's literally
implemented syllabus I have it working
in like four different environments and
four different RL libraries so it's
pretty easy to add to new stuff now
awesome we will have to Port it to work
with uh puffer I assume because of our
like our high performance M format you
will but it already works with mulb and
version of puffer like 0.7 or something
it doesn't even have messing either
initially um yeah if you're just running
on a single core then you know we could
cut out a lot of the complicated stuff
right yeah we can cut out most of the
complicated stuff then yeah so that's
the initial initial goal for that we're
also doing exploration work there's
Aaron in the call I'm still on stream
Aaron but we can uh we can chat the
research side not the business
stuff um hey how's it going
hello yeah how's life so Ryan apparently
has this and some other algorithms in
syllabus I still like that you've
reproduced those curves those curves are
useful cuz Ryan i' assume you didn't
bother with the Curves in the paper like
the theoretical
ones oh no I I well I did that a long
time ago I haven't checked them in a
while but I mean I have like the full
training curves reproduced actually I
can just yeah the training curves I mean
they have like a bunch of these like
theoretical sampling
curves yeah let me just send this um
whatever these things end up research
end being roundabout anyways just fine
I'll put one in I'll put them in chat
yeah we're making progress on the uh
hyper pram tuning stuff as well thereon
it's in depth now at the
moment
nice I have like literal thousands of
experiments on
this where do I send these
development all right Ryan I just put
them in chat the top one is me and the
bottom one is the paper m
uh sorry which chat you press the Open
chat button on the general chat that
we're in it'll open a place where you
can drop I've never used that feature in
my life
yeah very
nice yeah I think I I have the code for
that but I haven't read it in a long
time but I have these curves from
training on Crafter
gotcha I have a PR to merge at the same
time Spencer
did Spencer just added a crazy
environment for curriculum learning by
the way you you did get you did get Omni
going finally yeah I got Omni going
although I just copied the
implementation from um Jenny's code
which is not like I have to say the
implementations of both those algorithms
are like a lot different than the
picture you get from the paper they they
frontload all the uh the the um llm
calls at the start so they just like
cach them all into a big dictionary and
then they just reference that so like
the implementation in syllabus just
assumes you've done that work and put
the dictionary together and it just
calls it the same way that her code
calls it but wait how does that even
make sense the whole point of this was
they're constantly calling the
foundation model and being like hi what
should I do now what should I do now
yeah so rather than that they have this
dictionary that basically says given one
particular task is like given your
profession at one particular task which
of the remaining task space is
interesting so it's like an end byend
dictionary for every task so every task
has tasks that are interesting given
proficiency at this particular task and
you just have a full dictionary over the
entire task space and you just reference
that throughout training um that not how
I would have done it yeah it's it's not
on line but it makes sense
implementation wise because it' be
really annoying to call an LM in the
loop um for sure but yeah that's that's
how it was done in her code at least for
the crafter code I think the
um the like AI Thor and baby AI
experiments are newer I'm pretty sure I
I got the code base and looked at it at
some point I'm pretty sure she does it
the same way there but it's expect so
yeah that that's what I'm thinking um
but yeah that is uh that's how that one
works and then the learning progress
curriculum uh I guess you've probably
have you implemented the whole
curriculum or just like the individual
functions so far the individual
functions I was starting with the um
more full implementation stuff tonight
yeah so the um the learning progress
curriculum I was mentioning to Joseph
does like this huge valuation Loop over
the entire task space every like 20 2
batches so like every 25 uh algorithm
updates it just evaluates every single
task in the task space for a certain
number of episodes and then uses those
um uses that to calculate learning
progress and it doesn't do anything
online so it's not getting anything from
the training data um to calculate
progress where did you catch that cuz I
didn't catch that when I read thread it
I'm telling you it's not obvious from
the papers at all it's only in the code
um I didn't think
they yeah I didn't remember seeing code
oh it's in the Omni paper so Omni is
like fully based on this curriculum so
it literally uses the exact same
curriculum and then modifies it with the
LM calls so she has an implementation of
the lp curriculum in her code base I
didn't realize a followup I didn't
realize that was a direct
followup yeah it's a direct followup
yeah cool so we can just have the non
llm version as to start and we have like
Ultra fast pretty good
curriculum yeah so sorry what were you
saying Aon
basically
um what was I
saying you said but uh might have
been an interjection I don't remember
anymore okay um but yeah I have those
implant in syllabus although if you just
you can probably make it run faster by
implementing it directly
um but you still have that huge
evaluation Loop um the problem is you
can't online because you won't I was say
I was thinking just do it online like do
like you stay with your current sampling
method until you have data covering all
of the tasks and then once you have data
covering all of the tasks use all that
data to update your sampling
distribution you could do that but you'd
have to make sure that there's like some
probability on everything and I don't
think
um I'm trying to
remember I think that Jenny stuff has um
Jenny stuff for the lp has stuff set up
where it can work if you don't put full
probability Mass on
something yeah I think it can work with
a more like Smooth out distribution um
the the version they use at Omni has
this alization which it like subtracts
the random agent task success rate yep
um so if you use that then there will be
a lot of tasks with no um no probability
on them but if you take that away it
performs a little worse but you'll at
least sample every task occasionally um
well worse than that it just says it
just samples random Vector from numpy
Rand wait for
what uh it does so that random task
success is just sampled from
numpy wait what I'm pretty sure it
actually evaluates no no it evaluates
the first um like the agent that you
start with it it uses that as the
initial
Baseline maybe
I'm missed something
but I was pretty sure I
remembered uh I feel like I remember see
what you're talking about but I think it
was related to something else
although code bases are hard I'm
forgetting some of the
details
um but yeah uh another thing um there's
this other method sampling for
learnability which I tried on crafter
and it just works
better it's like here let me send that
plot that's one data point of course
um true but in their paper it works
better it's literally the exact same
algorithm but with a different like
rather than doing that whole complicated
learning progress It's just task success
times one minus task success it's like
they replaced all the learning progress
stuff with like a dead simple function
so we'll try both we have lots of did
you see Spencer's new
environment that's another one we can
try this on
nice so yeah sampling from learnability
works well in crafter and I also found
out that the algorithm that Omni uses in
crafter is just like you can replace it
with like 10 lines of code just
because I think they're the baby Ai and
AI Thor experiments are more advanced
and like the LM is actually doing
something clever but for crafter it's
just doing something really dumb it's
just taking out all the duplicate
tasks um
so you can even Implement that as an
option if you wanted
to we're not ever doing any experiments
on crafter we can do them on craftex
though that's fair
um actually I owe uh I owe uh Jacob uh
some compatibility patches for puffer
anyway so if we want to do that that's
directly in
scope sorry for for which environment
for just Jacob stuff in general we
started two new formal lab
collaborations uh with at nurs you know
we just discussions with the professors
one with Kathy Woo's group one with
Jacob forester's group um and then I
immediately got near lethal
pneumonia and that's kind of thrown
everything
off
um because you know I had to get the
company and the business side back on
track but uh yeah that'll be we'll be
resuming a lot of that stuff shortly
Goa I'm also slowly getting my fitness
back that's also
good yeah I mean if you want to talk
about how to implement the lp stuff or
the if you want to try it sampling from
learnability uh I'm happy to go over
some of that
stuff or we could
just well the thing is that we have
million step per second environments
um I think if you don't use
multiprocessing then I don't think
syllabus will cost you anything I mean
like the curricula themselves are slow
so like you have to why are the
curriculum
slow well for one learning progress does
a massive evaluation like sweep that's
almost as long as the actual training if
we do it
online say just do it online then I'm
still worried about doing it online
because your evaluation quality for most
of the is going to be like terrible okay
but like okay Ryan then we can we can do
evals at 2 million steps per
second um well then yeah then the
curriculum won't slow you down that much
if uh well will
because training itself is like a
million so it will still slow stuff down
a fair bit but like you know we can do
we can do all sorts of things because we
have fast speed sure well the curriculum
itself like if you if you really want to
do it fast it's just just like 10 lines
of python code for SFL that you can just
call directly from your main puffer lip
code like if you're willing to do a
little bit of integration work you can
make it a lot faster we were going to
stick it into the environment code
because it's a vectorized environment
see I
guess you could stick it into the
environment if you don't do
multi-processing and you don't have more
than one environment if you're literally
running a single environment then yeah
you well no we have we have like
thousands of but like they're just
they're done in a loop in
C they they do need to be synchronized
to some degree um no they're run
serially in a loop and C well no no the
curriculum should be synchronized I mean
yeah we can do that because it's like
they all have the same memory for stuff
for like learning progress and whatnot
like you don't have they're not on
separate processes where it's difficult
to sync stats and
stuff gotcha okay it's like very
transparent and
easy have you heard the good word of
C that should be
fine okay this took a while to get off
the ground but currently this is 19
score and 21 seconds with the new method
though the previous best I think we had
20 score and 18 seconds we are currently
but we are solving pong now in sub 20
seconds
very
nice and so you said you want to do this
over a maze environment yeah the maze
environment that I wrote I wrote like a
procedural gen with somewhat
configurable difficulty maze environment
configurable sizes can be reset to
different sizes dynamically like
observations all work out just perfectly
and stuff with that it's like uh
supports continuous and discreet
movement as well in the
Maze yeah okay so I assume that you want
to this will just be over like level
seeds mhm the curriculum well but you
could do level size as well yeah level
size too that's true and and there's a
difficulty parameter in the Maze
gem what do that control so the way I
was the way I was thinking to start it
off was just doing it over that
difficulty parameter well the only thing
is the difficulty parameter is not
entirely intuitive CU I don't know if
zero or one like zero might not be the
easiest and one might not the hardest
because it's technically like an
interpolation between two different
algorithms that produce different types
of
Maes gotcha might be might be a little
optimistic but ideally the curriculum
can figure it out it
should
yeah just throw everything into the
curriculum algorithm I mean I think that
just with simple domain randomization I
got it already to solve like decently
size
mazes like I had a policy that was doing
pretty reasonably oh yeah demand
randomization is great especially when
you train for a billion
steps but uh literally if you want to
try SFL that is the that's the algorithm
right there
it's it's as simp that from from
syllabus
thenon you want to try white you can go
look at that from uh from syllabus see
that works in puffer for the maze
yeah you can also
just uh that's sampling for learnability
it's let me send the paper gotcha the
success rate
version
yeah yeah I was talking with um Michael
at nerps about that
one
and uh I definitely think that like that
makes a lot of sense if you're
fine sort of alternating between getting
that data doing some training getting
that data doing some training if you're
going to do them both online
anyways is there a
difference um the difference is just the
metric then but again I'm I'm not sure
that these things work online I did want
to try it to be fair I was planning on
implementing it myself so this is giant
a fun
conversation yeah the the only issue I
would think is that if you get really
bad um um evaluation quality for some of
the tasks then you won't realize like if
a task has a 10% success rate and you
evaluate it like four times you might
just get a zero and so you won't
identify tasks that are like becoming
learnable until they're already like
pretty close to solved or like decently
learned which is kind of
counterproductive I don't know I might
be wrong fast stuff moves as well um I
mean if we're looking at like harder
environments that actually you're going
to take a while oh actually now that I
think about it so what I sent you is
sort of my like lazy version of SFL the
actual implementation which I do also
have samples it basically takes two
uniform distributions so they find the
top like K most learnable T most
learnable uh seeds and they um uniformly
sample from that 50% of the time and
then they uniformly sample from the
entire task distribution % of the time
so if you use it the way that it's
originally implemented where you have
like at least some sampling over all the
tasks then you'll always have like some
online data for all of them and it might
actually work pretty well
online oh I see what you mean by that
yeah okay it doesn't have to be 50% we
can tune that as well with the tuning
algorithm yeah yeah I've been tuning it
for my environments and I found like 75
tends to work pretty well but um you
could do whatever you want with it and
you could probably do it smarter like
rather than making it literally just two
uniform distributions you can like mix
them more
cleverly yeah I think there's there's
distributions for doing
that
gotcha um can you give me a pointer to
the syllabus
implementation sure uh it might be on a
testing Branch right now I'm trying to
write the paper right now so it'll be
merged in a week and a half but for now
oh you sending it to RLC that is the
plan I've been thinking about if I want
to take a day to write up puffer 2 for
RLC or if they can piss off I don't
know yeah I think it's worth a shot it
would be good for like they're probably
some industry people there to talk
with but like H
God the last conference nearly killed me
all right it's kind of put a damper in
things
it quite literally did nearly kill you
no like seriously do you know how much
it sucks getting your cardio Fitness
back it's really hard
work something like yeah that's uh why I
don't do as much of that as I should
like my average training run gets to 185
heart right
now I also don't exercise because
wouldn't it be a shame if I lost all
that
work that's totally the reason
is good to be in shape the uh the new
puffer facility is just it's straight up
a warehouse with a a bunch of servers
and a
gym everything you need that is it's
literally that's straight up what it's
going to be it's going to be
great but uh I don't remember if I got
this thought out or not but if you want
I think syllabus should still be easier
to use than implementing it from scratch
so you can like test stuff with syllabus
and then implement it if you want to do
actual sweeps but you can just like run
a single trial run it'll probably be
slow but I don't think it should be
horrible yeah the question is just like
puffer we have our own native end format
now that we have to fiddle
with I was going to say I think I think
that's the main thing to um mess with
right now I mean it doesn't go through
multiprocessing right for the native
like single process ones but it's
basically our our default format is a
backend that's all yeah syllabus doesn't
care what your vend is it just you just
Dr drop a single wrapper on the
environment and it
works uh I mean presumably you're
chucking a lot of that stuff through
infos is how you're sending it around
then uh no it creates like a separate
multi-ring pipe but if we're not
multiring it'll just be like a standard
pipe so should be I think that runs
faster if the same process basically
just creates an individual pipe not for
like another several months but like
when eventually people start migrating
to the newer python versions we're
probably going to kill pipes completely
from the implementation uh because it'll
be on threads and then we'll have even
more speed though uh for our native M it
literally doesn't matter because we're
so fast but it'll be good
otherwise I can't wait for that update
because so you're saying for
once python has threading that
works so you're going once for the no
Gill version comes out not when it comes
out when it's been around for long
enough that people should have updated
to it by
now because it's a breaking change
that's like a major breaking
change when is that supposed to be I
don't know it's not a huge deal because
like I said like our MS are so fast that
we do not
care and I haven't heard any updated
timeline for it but I'm looking forward
to it whenever they magically solve that
problem I I've kind of realized that in
order for puffer to be attractive to
companies right one I have to do some
business side stuff but then the other
thing is just we have to really lead the
charge on like RL progress and the way
to do that is not by being constrained
by the things that everyone else to Stu
on like everything needs to be fast by
default period that's it so like it
doesn't make sense for us to go like
spending a bunch of time on Atari
baselines or something like that
anymore
sure huge waste to compute oh I did do
one silly thing last night uh we have
multi-gpu and puffer now it's
experimental but it works and skips like
linear scaling I tested on uh 4
490s and uh it was those 490s were like
under volted or something so the single
GP speed was 200k and then it went to
close to 800k for four of
them so that's just how in depth is a
thing you can
do probably eventually at some point
we'll like get a tiny box or two for the
cluster but not a ton of them like it's
the single GPU stuff is still pretty
darn
good yeah I
I just don't I don't know I don't see
the benefit of multi-gpu stuff when most
of the models I'm working with anyways
are like too small for no it's mostly
for industry people gpus it's mostly for
because I've had multiple industry
people ask me if we had this so I
finally just like said okay I'll add it
and then I immediately went and messaged
the industry people like hey we got this
now but uh if you want to try these
methods I
I promise it'll be easy with syllabus I
can help set it up but I I've I've made
this stuff work with four different
libraries at this point and worked
out
puffer dude if if I can make this work
with puffer lib
0.72 in
neural I think I can make it work with
the upgraded version Look okay this
was it took a lot of work to get stuff
to this place where it is now
like neural and the multiprocessing
stuff in 07 was State ofthe art for the
time by a mile already just because
miles ahead now just mean it wasn't
already ahead then yeah it was still the
best option for n of two it's it's just
I think it's I I think it's got to have
like four or five times less development
time in it than the current puffer
version I can't remember how long ago it
was uh yeah I've been fulltime on this
since spring like last spring so yeah
we're coming the version we were using
was like it was like May of last year
right that's when you're running all the
stuff yeah so I
mean I'm excited to see how much better
it is it should be a lot better there
some there are some typos in the old the
old puffer lip code too oh
yeah but yeah I think if it works for
that it should be easy enough to add to
uh
mhm whatever you're working with now
yeah the main thing honestly in the
last the biggest thing in the last six
months has been all the environments in
puffer I mean that's been the main focus
and then in the last like a couple of
months the new algorithm side stuff has
been uh hyper parameter
sweeps a few academic collabs a few
other things around this
but yeah we have a few other things
lined up as well pretty
sweet we're GNA have to see with the the
590 availability that's going to be the
big
question true although I'm still I'm
still on the team of using slightly
older gpus for uh cost efficiency the
thing is they're not really efficient
because it's still hard to buy 490s in
bulk at the moment and uh you're already
going to pay you're going to pay between
5 and six grand for a box and he weighs
with a good CPU and stuff in it so the
GPU is only going to be like between
half and a third of the price anyways so
if you can save let's say you save 20%
the price of the box and you cut your
GPU speed in half that's not really
great cuz we are GPU bound now with our
MS
so yeah the new boxes that we're looking
at are 9950 X's 90s 128 gigs ddr5 nice
rrive nice fans nice Cooling and all
should be nice and
up we're getting the uh the new uh
puffer box 4 back in a couple of days as
well so hopefully uh that'll be one more
box for somebody to play
with probably K will get that one for
the work we're doing at the moment we'll
see I think I've resolved all the issues
with access to my cluster for now so I
have a couple more months of gpus
jez I I I don't know if I I probably
didn't tell this to you Aaron but our
cluster went like literally got hacked
so our entire you mentioned it last time
we talked okay yeah it was down for like
2 3 weeks and then my advisor is leaving
UMD so he's no longer allowed to sponsor
accounts so my account was going to get
shut down on top of that jeez I've
finally resolved all these issues just
got to get puffer
compute
yeah look I'd rather use umd's infinite
store of like 1080 gpus that no one uses
least
uh I get I thought
I this
me it's weird I don't know where it
would be then
me damn
it I have a cool photo somewhere but I
don't know where it went of like the
wiring and stuff in the new
facility it's going to be nice it'll
take a little time still and then the
the annoying thing is like 509s
apparently there's an issue where the
cables are melting on them so I'm going
to wait until that saw that on well
that's great yeah it's like I'm not
going to order a quar million dollars
worth of
Hardware right and have the cables
melt not
ideal that would be
terrible oh look at
that so interestingly this one took a
little longer to get
started we're going to see where it ends
up because after 85 runs
it's still not getting the 20 SC is the
weird thing at the low cost let it we'll
let it keep going for a bit though this
should be so much better than before but
I the training curves don't seem to be
like noticeably helping it is
odd oh yeah eron I did a thing where uh
the uh the hyper parameter sweep is uses
the entire training curves to train
models instead of just the final
Point
interesting I also simplified it I
realiz there's a way to simplify the
math tremendously so it's literally now
it's just the algorithm is uh largest to
expect it is just expected improvement
over nearest Paro Point that's it wow
you can simplify the math in an Ral
algorithm that's
surprising no you can't do that it's not
okay to to be fair the original
implementation of this I think you've
both seen this at this point the
original cars like 2,000
lines this is the map right here for the
new one it's pretty much just this
screen so like yeah there's a little
that'll get deleted but like there
there's the this final thing for the end
so that's the whole thing the whole file
is less than 500 lines when you cut out
all the comments and stuff it has three
different algorithms
implemented and they're really easy to
use protein well
done working name
protein I do have to get back to writing
but best of luck and I'm gonna go
get yeah let me know about this
curriculum learning project if you want
like help implementing stuff just to
talk about it chat weekend Ryan um
whenever you need a break from writing
okay that works for me um I have
literally spent the past
like I don't know few months maybe a
year implementing these these curricula
so I can definitely help out with this
speed it up I suggest the approach I've
taken to all the papers that have get
gotten accepted is to be as stupid as
possible and write them in like a day
and a half the papers I spend time on do
not get accepted I my problem is that
syllabus is such a bricking weird
library and it's designed in like the
dumbest way possible because it has to
be to work the way I want it to so
explaining it just it's so hard yeah
they don't know or care about those
details so you just don't put them
in but if you don't care about those
details the library just sounds like it
does nothing it's like the whole point
is making it like the the pitch is that
you could apply curriculum learning to
literally any RL Library code base like
any training code you have you throw
syllabus on it and it'll add curriculum
learning in like a couple lines of code
which makes no [ __ ] sense and it
doesn't doesn't make sense why that's
hard or if you understand why it's hard
it doesn't make sense how it's possible
so explaining it is driving me insane
yeah this is fun academic writing is
such a joy it is such a privilege to be
able to spend your the time in your 20s
doing
this I've spent the last
organiz ah yeah it's all right though
like you're you're set you're fine
yeah I've literally spent this week
organizing by defense which is taken so
many hours and like running shitty hyper
parameter sleeps for with this it's just
been the most draining work possible
that's the one thing I the one thing I
actually spent time on was my defense I
spent like no time on my thesis I I
think I spent like a total of maybe four
or five days on my thesis um no I'm not
talking about the I'm talking about
scheduling the defense like I haven't
yeah I haven't touched the presentation
yeah well the presentation took I think
was probably a solid three weeks worth
of work
yeah anyways okay I do have to go back
to I'll message you Aaron sounds good
see
you and yeah this is uh what I've been
doing here we're going to wait on these
experiments and uh hopefully I will ship
you this stuff you can play with it
who El just join this
thing hey hey how's it going
we hey how's it
going and a great I think we talked on
Ax briefly but like super briefly
sometime ago uh probably I can't see the
Discord name because I have the streamer
mode thing enabled because I'm on stream
still um oh you're on stream yeah you're
you're free to chat I just like I let
people know you're on the stream I mean
there're a total of five people on it so
whatever okay oh I'm
famous yeah I just I stream a lot of my
Dev by default it makes it really easy
for people to just drop in to the chat
and like get help on puffer get stuff
like every single week I get like
several users like asking me stuff on
how to like how to make puffer work or
how to do a thing so it's pretty
convenient for that yeah I'm guilty of
that I done that a few times for
you I mean that's why it's there it's
meant to puffer is meant to come with
the best support out
there it
does I hope so this is all I'm doing
with my time these
days anyway are you streaming only on X
yeah I'm on X twitch and
YouTube oh okay on YouTube as
well do you have some kind of counter to
like calculate total amount of viewers
uh I can see YouTube and twitch but X
only gives you total views it doesn't
show you lot like current Uh current
concurrent
viewers oh that sucks yeah so you can't
actually tell with X you can tell with
the other
okay but yeah like my uh nickname is
TFO like couple of months ago a bit yeah
good to chat with
you and I think we we are in
same chat on X
basically same chat is it oh one of the
group chats yes a same group chat yeah
is it the Henson one or the ML and like
whatever chat ml yeah yeah okay I post
some I post RL stuff in there
occasionally and then it's all language
model people so they just proceed ignore
it oh I I mean I am language model
people so I'm guilty of
that well there are cool things
happening over in RL land so yeah I know
but it's
so it's
scary I mean it's kind of moving not
anymore
buffer okay I I probably should try it
but like that's what we talked about
like in October and I I I said that I
should try it and I still
haven't if you just look on puffer doai
we have a dozen reinforcement learning
Ms that run at over a million steps per
second on a single CPU core and train at
hundreds of thousands to a million steps
per second as well one GPU by the way by
the way do you use some kind of ECS or
not um not exactly like Tech technically
the M's are all written in C which and
they're structs in contiguous memory and
an ECS works by looping over structs in
contiguous memory so like kind of but we
don't have like a a full ECS system
where we're adding components we're just
like kind of doing what an ECS would
do
okay you have similarly designed like
ECS similarly designed sure yeah ECS
light probably yeah it's I it's kind of
it's done per environment so it's a bit
more manual but at the same time there's
no ECF to like have to go through and
understand it's like any of our
environments we have some of the most
sophisticated RL environments but a
firste undergrad can understand our code
after they've taken their first systems
class that is the goal and that's how it
is
yeah because like oh yeah it's scary you
have 20,000 lines of C but then you
actually read the C and it's like this
is an if statement this is a for Loop
these are the the things that we use
that is all I I I I know I I just have
like some kind of I don't know saying to
to see I don't like it hey you've been
you've been lied to it's great it's the
easiest programming has ever
been no I don't uh like I haven't been
lied to like I interact with C like
constantly and I don't like do you
interact with C or C++ constantly
both okay well we we try not to make
things complicated and stupid I will say
yeah like um the problem with C is it's
like
old and uh like and it's both over
specified and under specified in in the
same time and is fair I it's the the
thing is like we're not doing things
where that becomes a problem we're
writing loops and
conditionals yeah I understand but like
I I still don't like that
language all right fair enough yeah
there really aren't that many options
for us to be fair at the moment like
there really aren't that many things we
could
use I mean there is
z there is but it's like the new it's
like the new trendy thing that isn't a
great idea to build a whole thing yeah I
understand I understand
yeah like
probably because of switching is going
down right now like by a
lot I mean I'd be more excited about
like better compile tools and stuff than
I would about the language because I
like I really don't need the
features you know no no I don't like uh
the things I hate about see the most are
something like build
systems yeah see we've been looking at
if we have to include cake or not and
it's I hate the builds yeah it that
that's completely
Fair it's not like it's not just uh the
fact
that c build system suck is that there
is like a dozen of
them and then you like look at something
uh like quick a c compiler you probably
I I don't I'm not sure if you saw it and
it has something like luas script that
generates ninja files that's awful we
would not do that the most we would even
look at would be cmake uh currently we
have build.sh is what we have uh the
only reason we're looking at cake is
it's not even necessarily because of the
C as much as that it's a pain to
interact with python and c and if we had
a cake if we had cmake it would allow us
to delete our really obnoxious setup. p
yeah like otherwise I just keep the
build S I mean Builder s has its own
problems like what if I want to use
Windows uh then you use a real operating
system we support Linux and Mac that's
it okay what if I want to use real
shell instead of
bash I don't know I don't know use use
the normal shell stop being advancing
I mean you could always type in bash and
then the script no I know I know I'm
just I'm just bitching
sorry look I mean I have lots of people
complain on these things but it's like
yeah okay zig's Zig is generally fine
like if if Zig were like the main thing
that people like if it weren't not this
like new trendy thing we would look at
it uh we'll absolutely not look at
C++ uh we're not going to look at Russ
we don't need the main thing that Russ
does is not something that we need it
just gets in our way so oh I understand
I understand yeah so that like that
doesn't leave very many other things and
I will say that like these environments
that we've been writing in C this has
literally been the easiest programming
has ever been for me it's like literally
easier for me now to make like the best
RL environments out there than it is to
do basic stuff in
Python no I I totally understand why you
chose c i i yeah
like
uh it's kind it's just kind of
irrational I don't know something my S
well we also have to tell people not to
submit dumb PRS and I see filter some of
the people but uh you know we still have
to like no don't don't go crazy with
macros stop it no no doing that right
stop going and digging up every single
feature in the C specification stop
doing that right
I means he doesn't have macros it has
templates okay whatever those those the
pound character forbidden okay stop
using yeah I understand you can use it
for constants if you must that's
all that's pretty much all we
do
sorry I think that somehow this version
of the hyper parameter sweep does Works
which is disappo
oh
that I included the full training
history as training data for the
sweeps I don't know how that would make
it do worse that seems weird to
me
okay yeah it's predicting I can see it's
like kind of crashed out here it's
predicting very low scoring
stuff which is very weird
so there's still more work to do on
this
[Music]
deal it's hard to do uh it is hard to
make best hyper parameter tuning off I
take some
work oh I I just went to your stream and
uh realized that you're Neptune enjoyer
as well we support Wan and Neptune but
I've been much more like Neptune has
been way
better yeah yeah understand now they are
missing some stuff I've been trying to
get them to add heat map uh heat map
coloration to their points like I would
like to be able to color them with a
heat map based on time so then I could
see what which points are being added to
this when like when they're being
added so if you just do a heat map
coloration so like you just you start
with blue and then you go to Red uh as
you add new points in then if I were to
look at like this Paro Frontier I'd
basically be able to see which portions
of the Pito Frontier are filled in at
which point in the sweep so you
basically cheat a third axis in your
plots except it's still really
readable okay yeah there's some fancy
like there's some visualization features
i' want but it's pretty nice for what it
is and it's really easy to download your
data that's I think their best feature
you do offline analysis like if their
plots don't work for you you just
download your data in one command and
then you make your own
great this is very
weird well there'll be time for more
analysis on this tomorrow let me just
make sure I haven't missed any DMS here
I'm going to have to go to dinner
shortly
by the way what
uh which stream has the lowest
latency which what which stream has the
the lowest latency probably
twitch okay well if you're going to be
if you're on Discord and you're watching
the stream with the audio on you're G to
have a bad time like you should mute the
you mute the stream yeah I did that yeah
I did
it it's probably twitch has the lowest
latency and lowest chat
latency it depends sometimes I have the
most viewers on Twitch usually it's the
most on YouTube it
depends I don't know it's fun streaming
though I usually have I usually have
like a few people watching me throughout
the day and then occasionally it spikes
up to like
10 that's like that's not nothing it's
not
considering that I'm literally just like
writing like intricate research code
most of the time yeah yeah like given
the fact that how much you stream yeah
okay I can't I can't find your Twitch
like uh it's I think it's j Suarez
5341 yeah okay same as my GitHub and
everything okay
yeah it's that
followers any paid oh like congrats with
round
100 funny I mean it's it's I wish X had
the view counter I don't think people
watch streams as much on X they just
kind of like noticed that they exist but
the main following I have is on x is at
6931 um I think the YouTube has yeah the
YouTube has like a couple thousand or
something but that's
mostly uh they mostly were from my
thesis
defense cuz this thing
has yeah this thing has 160k views so we
have almost 3K subscribers there I don't
really make too much YouTube content I
experimented with it but it's very like
hit or miss with the algorithm
I mean
like and it's like labor intensive yeah
and and I mean the goal is not add
Revenue either right like this literally
only benefits me if it gets like puffer
users or like uh you know if it gets us
more business as
well I mean like you
probably would want to do like sped
video I don't
know I mean we do
X has been the best honestly for uh for
business contacts so far oh definitely
like YouTube is not that great for
business like
no it's something really blows up like
occasionally something will really blow
up
right like my thesis video a lot a lot
of people saw my thesis video
um yeah and it led you a bunch of
credibility
yeah oh was fun you know I just I posted
my I posted my defense it's like this is
what I did right
yeah heck you can my whole thesis is
online as well you can go read
it 177,000
TRS in oh yeah we more than it's
probably last couple months
maybe that's mostly on one GPU as well
which GP do you have 490 I mean we have
uh the blog on here so like this is our
cluster right here this is our our scff
cluster right now oh uh how okay so it's
like uh nine machines
yeah eight of them with
49 uhhuh and the ninth one uh just a
login Noe it's got like an old uh a
really old like original v00 in
it
oh I
mean we 100 is not that bad of a GPU to
be honest I I think it's the original it
was released in like
2016 or 17 I think I think 17 like in
January like I remember like when um
like you usually gpus came with like
eight Tera flops or something and then
like uh they added T course and like NV
releases 100 ter terlop GPU and like
yeah honestly though like most of the
stuff at the time didn't make use of the
TAC cores effectively so like
yeah I mean like T course course didn't
get used used until
like like massively used until like 2019
2020 like
that I mean we there's probably a lot of
head room and puffer as well like still
like you could probably make our
training way faster than it is as well
we just haven't gone too too deep into
it definitely like
uh you could just like do it trying
start right
yeah you probably could just uh put our
one on your curs and it might be
passer we could put what on our
kernels like um uh how do you say it
like have you seen that Nvidia stuff
that where when they like uh use R1 to
like massively speed up uh default
uh Kels oh I mean they use like R1 to
write trit cels right
I didn't I didn't believe that I like
you're telling me that it's done better
than their hand optimized like their
existing hand optimized Kels for
existing
operations like here's
uh the thing
it's not that hand
optimized for for many of carals because
they are like just torch compiled
kernels and
like you don't do that much hand
optimizations with
that that's weird I don't know I think
probably launch overhead is the biggest
thing for us because we do I think we do
like 200 at least 200 data batches per
second if not
more I mean we do a we do a million step
per second training right and like if we
have a the for like the eval batch size
is like 4096 and then maybe we have a
train mini batch size of 8,000 or 32,000
at most probably 16,000 so it's like
there's a lot of launch overhead
associated with that
oh
yes
yeah
oh I mean the nice thing is puffer is
fast so like if you use bigger models
with lower laod overhead it'll scale
like better than you would expect
normally um wait you might take
advantage of Grace actually of
which of Grace Grace Hopper
like the GPU series what yes like GH 200
because they they have like way lower
latency between GP CP crazy
expensive back 50 per hour on Lambda how
much do they cost to
buy I don't know but bu 50 on
Lambda super chip
server how are they a buck 50 on Lambda
if they are $41,000
chips I mean how how do they rent these
things they're losing
money nobody is nobody knows how to use
them so they put like 3 months of
discount on them and like
uh like 50% off and go on like learn
what to do with them yeah and like do
they run torch out of the box I wonder
yes it can run torch out of the box but
it couldn't run VM like two months ago
oh so yeah we could try that technically
that' be
funny and and like it's arm stuff and
the there is a bunch of
issues with like interaction of arm with
uh python oh wait this is race
CPU yes what like be be because they are
on the same package latency is way lower
and like I see oh that's actually really
good it's like what dig is going to do
right that actually would be pretty big
for us if that worked
relase like like the thing is they'll
always 10 to the price this isn't a
consumer
card
uh yeah Theory digits would do the same
thing right when it comes
out as long as it's not like 10K right I
think the price Leakes were like 4K
right so our full servers plus six our
full servers cost around 5.5k right now
they just is 3K roughly but okay yeah
digits is 3K so that's not too bad oh
but that thing was like the perf on that
thing looked
terrible uh yeah I mean I think it's
built for llms pretty
much so for inference but like wait I
mean but you're going to have a lot of
memory transfer from CPU to
GPU uh during RL applications and so
maybe because of that you might just get
some uh strange
performance just from uh not having to
do with so many transfers we can we can
just rent on whatever it's puffer is
just a container so we can just download
our container on anything and just test
it I threw it on a vast 4 GPU instance
yesterday to test the new multi GPU and
yeah we have in dep multi GPU getes
linear speed up at least 200k to 800k
step per second on like one of the
MS yeah when uh for my puffer setup I
just did the the torch distributed and
on the puffer and it just worked like oh
you been doing it that's cool yeah I've
been doing it for months oh we just
added it to Dev dang it you should have
PR that stuff man it helps us well I
mean uh I I mean it's not I didn't do
anything crazy the only thing I did was
uh did uh like I took clean RL the torch
distributed there and then uh I I uh
made my um my environment um using
normal the only uh using the normal
setup the only thing I had to do was
make sure that the numb workers on the
vector on uh I I had to make the numb
workers lower than the CPU core count
but aside from that did you do did you
do distributed data parallel or data
parallel uh I don't even remember data
parallel working and yeah that probably
makes sense for the CPUs the thing is
rm's are so fast that most of them they
need one or two cores yeah
okay um like it's actually kind of crazy
the extent to which we can make like
cool Sims that are fast so neural MMO 3
this thing runs at 1.9 million steps per
second per
core like the uh the logic of this thing
and like this
is is it this is like massive
world you know however many agents it'll
scale linearly with number of
Agents okay by the way how open do you
use the cash
grind how do I use
what cash grind cash grind never heard
of it
yes like stuff that uh like uh lets you
see your cash misses and stuff but like
oh not at all yeah we don't like
literally but this is the thing this is
what I'm saying you do like the most
brain dead simplest possible stuff in C
and you still get this level of
performance oh okay so that's what
that's what I mean by it's easy no it's
literally
easy okay it's it's not I'm not a genius
it's just that people are writing python
code that's a thousand times too slow uh
yes like I mean python could be faster
but uh it's it takes some effort to make
python
faster it's it's harder than just
writing the thing in
C yeah yeah what what did you have to do
to do the uh the multi- GPU like what
did you change
I'm kind of wondering if you did
anything smarter yeah oh yeah so it's
not much like I I just it just kind of
worked for me yeah I mean I integrated
it as a separate option in the demo file
so that you could like run with the
existing clean puff RL um oh interesting
a few other things I also the logging
needed some work and I think there's
still a couple things with logging um so
that the dashboard will print aggregated
stats there are a couple things you'd
have to do there but uh MH that's about
it look at this by the way
about one thing about digits it's like
uh 30% of
5090 in
flops in terms of
flops uh I mean like depends I don't
know I mean the I I'm I'm going to be
honest with you it's probably I think
it's a good deal and the reason is
because uh um I mean if you're in RL
World maybe not but uh if you're in the
uh NLP world it's like uh the biggest
models like the cheapest way to run on
them is like a $20,000 Mech Mini at this
point ridiculous I think it's I think
it's
epic like the cheapest is kind of Epic
yeah I mean uh like a like a thread
Ripper is what you're saying like uh
[Music]
no literally epic Server Motherboard
with two CPUs huh
yeah like a like a like a thread
Ripper no thread Ripper is different
stuff like it's
different yeah they are expensive so
these boxes we're going to get we're
planning on buying 40 of
these
oh so you guys have funding uh how are
you guys uh like structured no it's
we're not VC funded it's bootstrapped a
lot of it's from personal cash but we do
have Revenue I mean we have
clients
nice I mean it's not an amazing business
model it's like this is not a business
model for uh made by somebody who likes
money apparently because we have all of
our stuff open source and like we make
stuff so easy that we make ourselves
redundant half the time but uh yeah it's
literally
just uh starting 10K a month for
priority service you get a slice of my
time looking at your problem and then uh
it goes up from there based on how far
outside of existing puffer stuff you
need and then if you need existing uh if
you need additional contractors on stuff
because I pull in my PhD buddies as
contractors I see interesting yeah I'm
hoping to be a client soon or at least
uh my client's hoping to be a client
soon hey awesome uh yeah we'll see we'll
see where it goes it's basically uh
we're getting um I I posted a video of
it uh of our system working now uh we're
going to scale into 3D eventually and it
starts getting really hard let me see
what did you post H it was a while ago
hold on I might be able to give you a
quick uh rundown of
stuff yeah I mean it's pretty much our
goal is to just be the place that makes
RL easy for folks and uh to be able to
sustain like you know a small profitable
industry lab yeah this is what we got so
far I just I just link uh in general I
uh pinged
you I posted it a bit
ago what is the
task uh it's solar panel array
optimization and so uh okay yeah the
each one of those little blocks are
solar panels and then you have to uh lay
out the wire in such a way that it's
efficient for the person who's placing
it and right now the uh the people who
are um the people who actually write
this are gen engineers and they spend
hours drawing these in AutoCAD that's
crazy and so uh and it's it's a
surprisingly difficult
problem
meete
so but uh yeah like obviously an NP
complete thing you can tell just looking
at
this uh I mean it's BF finding so it's I
think it's in
complete all right I do not have
a yeah I don't have a cache of NP
complete problems in my head to map to
map to so yeah my brain goes uh like
it's it seems easier than it is yeah
it it looks like it should be super
simple but it really isn't and
especially when you get into the more
complex Horas this one's a pretty good
complex one I think there's structure to
it
potentially
yeah okay I probably was wrong about
when be complete but still it's still
hard yeah we uh we'll throw
our the founder spent like three years
trying to generate an algorithm to do it
huh for a while and uh it doesn't really
work so uh I mean the best algorithm is
RL at this point oh we can get and then
eventually we're going to go into 3D but
that's
later actually since this is these are
these look like procedurally generated
layouts um as long as the Sim is fast uh
we are doing new stuff I I think you
probably heard earlier on curriculum
learning like we're kind of doing
research in a bunch of areas that are
hopefully going to be applicable to
various industry
problems
Co this is interesting so what does that
actually mean I guess uh basically you
would start with like smaller like
smaller layouts of stuff and uh the
algorithm would be able to essentially
bootstrap itself so it learns way
quicker to solve the harder Problems by
first learning to solve easier
ones yeah interesting yeah I mean this
is like the stuff we do for well we do
it for for oursel but we also do it for
clients as well that's kind of what
we're doing to an extent like uh we
start on smaller arrays and train it on
that and then we uh like we keep
stepping up and uh uh modifying the
rewards and then training upward because
uh like the rewards that work for the
problem uh like to solve aren't
necessarily the rewards that work for
the problem to be
optimal yeah so I mean that is that's
correct learning in a in a nutshell
there and there's there are better
algorithms and smarter ways of doing
that that's actually one of the active
areas of research that we have in puffer
right now interesting yeah that's a
fairly newe effort but uh like for
instance we have a procedurally
generated maze environment that we use
as a test bed for this so you can start
with the simpler mazes and then solve
harder
ones I'm also uh it's seven so I should
probably go grab dinner
but yeah that's a cool environment let
me know uh let me know how that's
progressing we can definitely do stuff
for that yeah that I mean that'd be
great um we're getting pretty close to
uh um we actually doing our full uh
Alpha release that's that's a I think a
couple months ago um we have the what
makes it really complicated is there's a
um that's just a single string length of
I think we have 12 in that one but uh it
has to support multiple different string
lengths and you have to be able to
select it in other words the model has
to be able to select it and so it gets
really crazy really fast um but we're
getting really close and uh once we
scale on the 3D uh we're hoping that we
can bring you on but uh we'll see how
that goes yeah let me know how that goes
is this uh is the company like a startup
or a larger company or uh startup okay
cool I have special terms for startups
as well so if I need to bring
contractors on they ask for cash but I
take cash or Equity so sometimes that's
luse your own
companies oh yeah that'd be really
cool sorry
yeah all right well uh nice talking to
you I'm I'm actually gonna go eat two
yeah great chatting I gotta go get
dinner folks um so I'll just do the
YouTube outro and or the YouTube twitch
stream outro and uh yeah I'll chat with
you all later so for the folks
online all the stuff is free in open
source you can check it out on . go
ahead and start the GitHub really helps
us when people start the GitHub it's one
of the main metrics that we track you
can join the Discord if you want to get
involved in discussions like these or
use the library or contribute back to it
don't really need a huge uh any real
experience in ourl a lot of the people
have come in just with software
engineering background we help train
people in that
area and if you're looking for more
content we've got a Blog and you can
also follow me on X where there are a
bunch of Articles you can't find
anywhere else the main place I post news
as well thank you and uh I will probably
be
back yeah I probably won't be back after
dinner I'll be back tomorrow morning
soon as I'm up uh a question one
question are there are those FP files in
MOBA there are no F files in MOBA that
sounds horrible oh sorry what is dota
fast is is like fragment Shad what
Shader that's just PLS oh oh oh it's
glsl
justs and that's it's just for it's just
for like that's not used at all during
training that's literally the only
reason that glsl is there just to show
you it's just decoration so for the
puffer MOBA there's this like wavy
background you can see and then also
like the edges of the tiles they like
glow they have this Edge on them that
glows and like Fades and there's also
like this like this type it's just for
decoration it makes all this stuff
pretty that's all it does
okay yeah yeah my code counting utility
uh
like yeah that's all it is misunderstood
that for C FP we do not have anything
crazy yeah we really don't have anything
I I understood like I I I looked at uh
the background in this is a Shader
technically um that's pretty much it we
don't have this is the most complicated
Shader that we have everything else is
pretty straightforward like the
background piling here is a Shader
that's
it yeah like all shaders are like 300
lines of code mhm together yeah they're
tiny it's it's 20,000 lines of C around
10,000 lines of python and a few small
odds and ends that's
all
like it says that it's
like
168 16,800 of PC yeah it's not that much
16,000 it should be more than that it
should be when we counted it I think we
have it in the uh the demo
trailer uh I mean like I don't it
doesn't count blanks and it doesn't
count
comments probably that yeah it was
probably 20,000 just like file
length yeah file length is 20K but like
actual meaningful code is like 17K
roughly not bad 17K lines for like a
dozen environments actually we just
pulled in uh another big end
contribution and then there's one more
that's almost ready to be PR so it will
be 20K pretty soon we've got a
contributors building Cool Stuff what
was that an uh it's a 3D maze
environment it's like a 3D Puzzle
environment oh yeah that he talks just
now Spen environment yeah it's in it's
in dep I think it's Tower climb but I do
have to go to dinner now so it's good
chatting I'll be back on tomorrow
B PE thank you bye-bye